Business Insider reports the internet is  aghast and maybe even a GOG at the couch  Elon Musk sleeps on when he works late  at Tesla he showed us the couch during  an interview last week at his Silicon  Valley Model 3 car factory last time as  you're actually slept literally on the  floor cuz the couch is too narrow yeah I  was gonna say and you know I have to say  it's not even a comfortable couch either  no it's terrible this is not a good  catch after seeing that report a  California man was moved to start a  GoFundMe page called by Elon Musk a  couch in one day the campaign raised  more than five thousand dollars  exceeding its goal